[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes i'm john connolly the spectators
news editor coming up today
boris johnson managed to survive a
confidence vote this week he should
technically be safe for another year but
james forsythe says the plots against
him are going to keep coming james will
discuss the pm's fate with sir anthony
selden
owen matthews writes in this week's
magazine that vladimir putin is
weaponising starvation in ukraine aidan
hartley meanwhile says that bad
governance is to blame for grain
soldiers in africa they're both joined
to discuss the russian grain blockade
a new migrant accommodation is being
built in stafford where i live but is it
a good idea to host 500 asylum seekers
on the outskirts of a small west
midlands town i'll speak to enver
solomon
you may have seen a poll last week
saying that swedish people were the
least likely in europe to offer food to
guests who come to visit but are the
swedes being unfairly maligned lisa
bierwald will be on the show to defend
swedish hospitality
and finally sports journalist neil clark
writes in this week's magazine about the
danger and glory of the isle of man tt
he'll join the show
before we get going why not subscribe to
the spectator you can get 12 weeks of
the magazine imprinted online for just
12 pounds we'll also give you a free 20
pound amazon gift voucher just go to
spectator dot co dot uk forward slash tv
offer and why not subscribe to our
youtube channel as well click the red
subscribe button at the bottom of the
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
on monday 148 tory mps voted to oust
boris johnson as leader of the
conservative party with 211 in support
but is the worst yet to come for boris
johnson james decides writes in this
week's cover piece that the 1922
committee which sets the rules might
allow another vote on boris johnson in
the next few months
to explain james versailles joins me
with sir anthony selden who's written
biographies of the last six prime
ministers james anthony thank you for
joining us
now james start us off boris johnson's
face the no confidence vote this week he
won that he technically should be safe
for another year
you write in this week's cover piece
that there are more challenges coming
there are plots going on can you um tell
us a bit about that to get us started
so the tory party knows it has a problem
with plotting that's why it's put these
rules in place that make it very hard to
remove a leader
but the point about these rules is the
bar on another confidence vote for a
year you know that can be changed by the
executive 1922 committee
at any point it chooses to and whilst i
don't think it's going to change those
rules after these bar actions coming up
later this month or anything like that
i think if uh in a few months time boris
johnson's political position has
continued to deteriorate if he's been
criticized by the privileges committee
then i think there is a real possibility
that they they will change the rules
after all the 1922 committee answers to
the tory back benches uh which voted
against boris johnson on monday night
um anthony how long do you think the pm
can sort of keep going yeah i mean he
said his win this week was um was
convincing do you think that's right
well i agree with james uh rather
boringly uh but i completely do i think
that is
uh right uh
myself i don't think he will still be
there in the spring
but i don't think we can say at the
moment exactly when he'll go we can say
what um and how he will go and uh there
are three ways he can go i think the one
that people are getting wrong at the
moment is falling on his sword
uh and i'd give that about a 20 25
chance he may simply just feel that this
is so damaging his legacy
as prime minister that he will go and
try and claim some high ground
uh doing it i was with someone
the other day who told me that
that was exactly what he had uh
told him that he would do i mean of
course that's boris and he will uh cast
flies over people so i give that about a
20 25 chance 20 25 chance somebody in
cabinet i mean three people in cabinet
on their own could do for him and that's
uh rishi who might
uh rob actually who might uh might
more likely than we
think he might and gov who won't uh
because having knifed
a boris once before and uh and having uh
knifed cameron he's not going to
um get rid of uh
you know a third person and and the the
other way and i completely agree with
james about this is the 1922 committee
and
as was clear when writing the book with
raymond newell on
uh theresa may
they will make up their own minds the
1922 committee uh graham brady is
extremely independent-minded as james
said in his column this week they have a
very shrewd he has a very true sentence
of the the feeling amongst the
parliamentary party and if uh this uh
the turbulence carries on if the
constituents keep on saying
uh this is going to be a terrible thing
uh for them and that they are going to
fall apart the general election that's
all that tory mps care about is getting
re-elected uh then very quickly they'll
meet together they met together uh and
got rid of theresa may
um by threatening to change the rules
they had this secret ballot um and put
the result in envelopes and uh graham
brady then went to theresa may and said
um if you don't do what uh we want
we will get this out into the open so i
think 60 likely uh the the way of
falling and we simply don't know when
it's going to happen i don't think i
just add as a final caveat
i can't think of another prime minister
of the 55
uh prime ministers who is quite like
boris johnson and not the least uh being
able just to
uh pull rabbits out of a hat but it's
going to have to be
a pretty deep hat and a pretty
extraordinary rabbit but he is a
phenomenon he has qualities that very
few of those other prime ministers
uh of have had so who knows it's going
to be exciting
i mean james you say it sort of seems
there's going to be like a tipping point
with the 1922 committee do you think
that point could be the two by-elections
we've got coming up
i think those two by-elections are too
soon i i think one thing that is
one cabinet lawless said to me last week
so before we knew that the confidence
vote was going to take place this week
but they thought boris johnson's moment
of maximum vulnerability was the monday
after those two by elections and if for
confidence ballot had been called then
boris johnson could have been in real
trouble but because this uh uprising was
organic rather than organized
it took place before the by-elections
and they fell 32 votes short i think
looking at that result if they'd waited
until after these bar elections they
might well have got the numbers but i i
don't think you can have a system where
you choose to have another vote just two
weeks later that that would be too soon
so i think you have to look at other
potential flash points and there is the
broader political situation and then
there is there is obviously this whole
issue of the privileges committee
investigation into into his statements
to the commons which i think which i
think has the the which could people say
oh but that is a reason when that
concludes to allow another ballot to let
tory mps reflect on its findings
and anthony sort of taking a step back
slightly um there are historical
precedents for this kind of thing for
these kind of challenges a lot of people
are saying that means boris johnson you
know being forced out is inevitable do
you agree with that and can you sort of
look at a bit of it of the history of
historical precedence there
well
we can obviously push that historical
precedent too much but i think there are
three relevant ones and they all point
to is there a viable successor around
that party might not like them very much
but at least around whom they can
coalesce who will stand a better chance
than the incumbent of uh doing well in
the general election and avoiding a
civil war now with thatcher there was a
credible alternative he didn't win and
that was hezeltine uh with john major in
1995 there wasn't a credible alternative
it was john redwood and he did extremely
well and with theresa may there was a
highly credible alternative when boris
johnson uh decided to emerge in the
course of 2019. so i i think moments i
completely agree about the the
by-election's already been priced in
it's you know it's going to be a total
fiasco uh and people have accepted that
and then if it's not such a bad fiasco
it will look as a you know be billed as
a triumph um and you can't possibly have
one until the the long summer um i think
things will get difficult when people
start coming back at the end of the
summer and and that is a moment of real
peril if by then there is a clear
success and maybe broken ranks resigned
from cabinet or maybe jeremy hunt who uh
comes up very openly
and with significant uh backers i think
uh that everyone's very keen to avoid
and and who can blame them uh a bloody
civil war the kind of uh uh
nadine doris attacks on jeremy hunt um
to the power of a hundred um i mean
that's going to significantly damage the
party even against kierstama in a
general election so i think uh if the
turbulence carries on if if the
members in the country voters are still
very anti um boris johnson but pro the
party but anti boris johnson and if a
clear successor emerges then i think uh
that's going to be extremely difficult i
don't think number 10 even if they get
organized this time will have the
capability
but i'm just going to mention the
proviso we never quite know what boris
johnson will pull out next i mean he has
had the worst epidemic
he reacts very well to events he's had
brexit he's had uh the russian invasion
of ukraine it might need a meteor
hurtling towards earth
to get boris johnson reminding us of why
we need to have his style of leadership
short of that not certain there is much
and james it doesn't seem like the
opposition to boris johnson has been
particularly organized at this stage do
you think that's going to change as the
sort of weeks and months go on
i mean there is a difficulty in that
changing because the opposition to boris
johnson comes from all sorts of
different wings of the party and all
sorts of different intakes i think the
individual groups that are opposed to
boris johnson will become more organized
in in their actions but i don't think
you will see that much coordination
between those groups because uh they um
they can't agree on who they would like
to succeed boris johnson so i still i
don't think you're going to see
all 148 tory mps who voted against him
kind of acting as a collective group
i think you'll see individual groups
become more organized but i think this
will i think this will remain uh
uncoordinated
because
it encompasses so many different parts
of a tory party which obviously means
that the the plot can't have potters
can't have strategic patience which they
should have demonstrated this week but
it also does make it more difficult for
number 10 because you know if it was
just one centrally organized plot you
could you could hope to disrupt that
it's much harder to disrupt a whole
series of things which is what it's
trying to deal with at the moment yeah
and there's a good point i mean anthony
what would your advice be for boris
johnson now or do you think he's in a
bit of an impossible position
i i do i think he's been a much better
prime minister than many people thought
including many of his uh critics he has
delivered that extraordinary general
election victory the highest since
thatcher he did up pretty well overall
on covid he did
deliver on brexit after uh three entire
years of bitter uh divide he has
delineated a leveling up strategy even
if he hasn't uh filled it in he has uh
produced extraordinarily low
on unemployment um
and that to to carry on what can you
possibly achieve not since 1832 is one
party won a fifth general election in a
row even with boris johnson's magical
skills it's going to be a pretty tall
schlep why on earth would he want to
carry on
and have more of this humiliation why
wouldn't he want to take the dignified
paths of saying look i got it wrong
i'm now dividing the party i love
we need to get this sorted out uh
clinically and quickly i'm gonna fall on
my sword
yeah and james uh as a last point there
do you think there's any hope that boris
johnson can can cling on there
i i was talking to one cabinet minister
about this on monday as the voting was
taking place
and i said oh look you know whenever you
you have a confidence vote and story
leader it it tends to be the beginning
of the end because because the threshold
to call a confidence vote is so high at
15 of the parliamentary party as soon as
the vote is happening
that that begins to to to be begin the
process of ending a leadership and it
then becomes a question of when not if
and this cabinet's replying saying oh
yes but but he has that kind of ian both
from like quality
that he can turn things around from
unexpected situations and so i think of
response you can't rule anything out
what i think you can say is that any
leader who has had uh 41 of their
parliamentary party vote against them is
in an extremely vulnerable position
whatever the rules say uh and i think i
think the other problem for him
is that it is very hard to see where the
good news is coming from we're about to
enter into a very difficult economic
period and it is hard to see where the
relief comes from for this government
what is the thing that enables boris
johnson to turn the corner that i think
is the difficulty for him brilliant
thank you james and thank you anthony
vladimir putin is using starvation as a
weapon of war spectator contributor owen
matthews writes this in this week's
magazine the russian leader he says he's
restricting the world's access to
ukrainian grain pushing up prices and
making the poorer suffer
meanwhile aidan hartley the spectator's
wildlife columnist says that in africa
putin isn't the problem poor leadership
is to discuss owen and aiden join me now
owen and aiden thank you for joining us
now owen you write this week that putin
is weaponizing starvation in ukraine can
you um tell us a little bit about that
and explain the current situation there
with regards to sort of food and
blockades
well um it was very clear right from the
beginning in fact it was one of the
earliest indicators that russia was
serious about a war in ukraine because
of its naval mobilization and actually
sort of kicked in
very early on in the year
the russian navy mobilized as many
troops as many uh warships as it could
to the black sea
and um
the idea was to economically strangle
ukraine and
we presume to
uh
support some kind of seabourn assault on
odessa uh we can't know their minds but
it seems that that was what they were
preparing for uh the upshot
of that has been um that
um thanks in large part to three
particular attacks right in the first 24
hours on the of the war on international
non-ukrainian flag ships in the black
sea the you that the russians clearly
intended to
uh strangle the ukraine economically
and the uh result of that um is that a
gigantic amount of uh of grain 22
million tons of grain and other foods
are stuck in ukrainian ports
um
now the ukrainians claim that that
amounts to a deliberate
russian
policy of starving the world and
starving africa and i know that you that
aiden actually
has
uh written very convincingly that
actually there are other reasons why
africa specifically is experiencing food
shortages but
regardless of the african situation
which we'll debate in a second it is
certainly true that large swathes of the
middle east and particularly the levant
are very heavily dependent on ukrainian
grain and already we're seeing
significant price spikes across the
world in food
and according to the ukrainians that's a
deliberate weapon of war that's being
used by putin putin himself has actually
denied it he's saying we're not
blockading ukrainian ports we have no
problem with ukraine exporting food it's
the ukrainian mines that are the issue
but the de facto what we have is a wall
that is stopping
one of the world's sixth largest grain
exporter in the world ukraine in getting
its
food to international markets
and aiden what's your view on that i
mean is is the ukraine conflict going to
affect sort of food security in africa
at all or are you saying it's it's not
very much
i thought owens piece was very good and
i don't disagree with anything that he
says um i and i don't disagree that
putin's actions in ukraine
are not driving prices up for cereals
particularly wheat and
maize
um
but you know there are several factors
here
um that
mean specifically for africa
uh the humanitarian food situation
is is not that stressed because agencies
like the united nations can access food
even when there are export bans like
there are in indonesia for palm oil and
india for wheat
and although prices are higher they're
able to
reach those populations that are in need
definitely prices have have gone up
across africa and for those countries
like egypt and sudan that are quite
dependent on on wheat imports especially
from
russia and ukraine
there are there are going to be
hardships but in my piece
i address specifically the situation in
africa when it comes to starvation i
mean
what's what i've been told is that uh
there are 13 routes out of ukraine by
road by railway and also down the danube
and although the capacity uh isn't there
to match the ports the seven ports out
of ukraine
um there are other factors involved like
convoys being held up at the european
union borders for up to a week because
of health checks and so on and i think
that you know there are challenges just
like there are in oil and gas supplies
to europe that need to be addressed and
people need to build capacity to be able
to take
uh 22 million tons of grain out of
ukraine before the winter wheat harvests
begin in july
and one sense is that you know wheat
prices are so high that um that that uh
transporters and farmers are going to
somehow manage to you know take a quite
large chunk of that out
um and so i sort of feel that the market
is going to correct itself do you agree
with that arenal do you think this will
be too many bottlenecks of um getting
grain out not via the sea
well i mean in this question just like
like so many other um uh
issues on the ukraine war um we're we're
sort of back to world war one sort of
metrics you know from from you know
trenches and artillery jewels but
actually also
you know railways you know there there's
actually a tremendously significant
problem with railways and that is that
russia famously is on a different gauge
to eastern europe and currently the uh
the poles and the ukrainians are uh
building literal parallel tracks in
other words ukrainian great engaged
tracks going into poland and polish
creation tracks going into
into ukraine but obviously those kind of
infrastructure projects are going to
take quite quite a long time so so the
the one of the major bottlenecks is that
literally physically russia ukrainian
grain has to be unloaded and reloaded at
the border uh which is uh
a tremendous logistical problem and um
the the
by according to the ukrainians
themselves
um
the agriculture minister said uh this uh
this week that they they can maybe push
to export two million tons uh by rail
and road but you know that's obviously
in ten percent of of of of the potential
they could export by
um
uh by sea the the the the real crunch
and the question is going to become um
what's going to happen with the russians
and uh mariupol so the russians claim
that they are going to get the port of
mariupol up and running and in fact they
already said they've done that so what
happens with you with russians
selling ukrainian grain from mariopol to
international traders
and that's actually the kind of moral
question that the
kind of moral spanner that the russians
love throwing in the works because it's
divisive like do we
maintain our moral superiority and
refuse to buy this ukrainian grain not
sure who it belongs to but it's been
captured by the russians
are offloaded into the international
ships with the russian guarantees their
security and let africa staff or do we
stick to our principles i mean and and
that's going to be a debate because in
fact uh ironically the major exporters
very shortly of ukraine and grain are
going to be the russians
last week the uh chairman of the african
union uh mackie sal went to
sochi to meet putin and described
african countries as the victims of the
ukraine war
um and and it appears that in the wake
of that meeting um quite a lot of that
grain owen might be uh possibly on its
way to africa so perhaps some side deals
were made um
i mean feeding into this uh crisis about
uh grain supplies in the world
is a an alert about um
a drop in harvests due to drought in
different parts of wheat growing areas
i mean there are going to be bumper
harvests in australia but apparently
america will be down but you know where
there's still a lot of food in the world
a lot of grain
in my piece i talk about the situation
in africa where a a drought
is compounded by
appalling conflicts across the sahel and
the horn of africa have driven um large
numbers of people uh to the brink of
starvation and um
and all of the aid agencies are are now
starting to
uh
say that unless food is delivered uh uh
quite soon then people will begin to die
and and they they believe that the
ukraine conflict is compounding that
situation
um but but in fact there are you know
these longer-term reasons why
there are problems with food supply in
the middle east and and in africa and
and a lot of it has to do
not with climate change um and not with
a drought even but conflict and
appalling government policy
and um corruption and the reasons that
uh
bring famine up as a as a topic on an
almost annual basis when you hear ngas
like oxfam saying that it's the worst
famine for 40 years again and again and
again
uh every year but um
you know as we know you mention
uh uh joseph in the book of genesis um
you know this is a problem that goes
back over 3000
years um you know seven
uh uh
fat years and seven lean years um people
need to prepare
uh for these events and um they just
don't seem to
have been able to do that
owen do you do you get the sense that
it's sort of being played slightly for
pr reasons on both sides when it comes
to russia and ukraine on the grain issue
or is that an unfair
characterization
no um uh
you're absolutely right i mean the the
one thing the ukrainians have been
superlative at is um sort of mission
display sort of message discipline and
at their pr so in fact it is
tremendously emotive um
thing to claim that russia is starving
the world it's another thing to throw at
the russians um technically speaking in
fact
the russians are correct in so far as
the
ukrainians themselves have confirmed the
real technical logistical problem of
getting grain out of odessa is the mines
the ukrainians themselves say it's going
to take six months to clear the sea
mines on the sea roads into odessa
um true or not the russians claim that
they've actually demined the approaches
to mariupol um in less than less than
two months although the as of c is
actually much shallower than the black
sea et cetera i mean there are technical
issues
but the ukrainian minds are actually if
the russians were to agree tomorrow to
lift the blockade and everything was
hunky-dory they actually couldn't do it
because of their own minds so in the
sense the ukrainians
are milking this uh for propaganda
purposes it's true but also it doesn't
mean that it's not the case that the
russian invasion has caused them to not
be able to export the grain both things
are true they're very good at pr but
actually they have mind that they're
imports on the other hand they uh it is
the russians that have caused the
situation and uh because of the mining
the russians are not in in fact the ones
that could
resolve this immediately the ukrainians
now have to spend a long time actually
demining their ports uh and thank you
and and finally aiden do you think it
kind of suits the west as well to kind
of pin all the blame on on famine on
russia at the moment are they sort of
shifting blame slightly
i think that um the
uh
uh the bodies that are making uh most
noise about famine in africa are
uh african leaders such as the uh
chairman of the african union um meeting
putin last week
um and i i think a crisis like this is
an opportunity to once again
review um policy and governance in
africa and try to get uh uh rulers to be
more um accountable and to introduce
better policies that uh
involve you know
tapping into the fact that africa has
sixty percent of the world's arable land
but most of it undeveloped um you know
the incentives for local farmers across
africa
uh have been so low that um global
supply chains have just made it easier
to dump the production of nebraska on
the horn of africa every year
with subsidized wheat from north america
um and so i think that's where you start
um
but uh yes i think that uh aid agencies
western governments are as
ernest says about the ukrainians milking
it for all it's worth
that's not to say that the prices are
not causing a lot of distress across
poor areas of the middle east and africa
um but um the fact is that uh
the the the same thing happened during
covid when you know suddenly the world
seemed to have been caught with its
pants down because it had been relying
so completely on china for all of its
supply chains and and now we find that
you know the system to deliver food
around the world particularly to the
poor is so fragile um that you know
there is there is no
uh store to uh protect people for the
next year or so and so you know we are
on the brink of of of crisis thank you
aiden and thank you owen
and i'm in the magazine this week
writing about a new migrant
accommodation center which is opening up
in my town of stafford in the west
midlands right in the magazine that for
all its joys stafford maybe isn't the
best place to put 500 migrants there's
not much to do there there's not much in
the way of hospitality or entertainment
i look a bit at the local backlash and
then i also look at the home office
policies that have led to lots of these
accommodation centers being opened up in
unsuitable places
and i'm very glad to have enver solomon
ceo of refugee council join me to
discuss
thank you enver for joining us on
spectator tv
now before we get into the specifics i
think
it's probably very difficult to have
this conversation if you don't kind of
understand a bit of the general
background
about the asylum processing application
process going at the moment um i mean
when i was looking at it i was amazed at
how big the sort of backlog is at this
stage so maybe ever could you start us
off by sort of giving us a bit of
background about that and kind of the
impact it's having sort of wider well
the backlog is is really quite
astonishing we've got over a hundred
thousand people
as of this moment in time
waiting for a decision on their asylum
claim
we've got well over 70 000 waiting more
than six months
and we've got indeed you know thousands
and thousands tens of thousands waiting
even over a year and and some waiting
five years or even longer than five
years now this isn't a system
which is orderly efficient and effective
this is a system which is deeply chaotic
incredibly expensive
and just not functioning well at all
and it has a huge cost human cost on
individuals lives you know we work with
people that have come here who have gone
through extremely traumatic
experiences are often in recovery mode
in their left languishing in limbo for
weeks months years on end
not being given information about what's
happening to their case
not able to work living on less than six
pounds a day
limited access to health care to support
sometimes with
you know really serious health
conditions
and it causes them huge distress and
anxiety even to the extent that we've
seen people
self-harm and in some of the worst cases
resort to attempting suicide
i mean it's absolutely dire i mean
as a result of this we've sort of seen
accommodation fill up we've got i think
around 30 000 37 000 people
being put up in hotels and hostels
rather than proper accommodation
um all the accommodation seems to
basically be a breaking point everyone
is absolutely full so that's kind of
where my piece comes into a bit i guess
which is the home office seems to be
sort of scrambling around a bit um it's
trying to open new accommodations up
which is how we sort of end up with
stafford court in my town so i think
it's around 500 asylum seekers gonna be
sort of plonked on the edge of town i
mean in my view i write about this in a
piece a bit so i'm sort of making the
point that stafford isn't maybe the best
place for these people and that it's
kind of a bit in the middle of nowhere
it's i like living there very much um
it's got a lot going for it but it's
also very quiet there's only a few shops
bits of entertainment that kind of thing
and the site itself is outside of town i
mean i'm interested in your view do you
think that's a bit unfair do you think
maybe these kind of schemes can work in
a place like stafford or do you think
i've got that right
i think it is unfair and and you know i
think it becomes and is now crisis
management and in that crisis management
the home office loses what is probably
the most important message from the
whole windrush saga and the conclusions
of wendy williams who produced a very
important report into the lessons
learned of windrush which is that the
home office should always see the face
behind the case and when you have this
crisis management and having to scramble
around as you say to find accommodation
likes happened
in your in your hometown
then
the home office loses sight of the face
behind the case it loses sight of the
human being of who they are
their needs their requirements the fact
that they're highly traumatized the fact
that they're plonked in location with no
support with no access
to services and having to just get on
with it and do the best they can now i
know some people might they therefore
think well you know
at least they've got accommodation at
least they've got a roof over there at
least the state's doing something for
them
but you know i would say to anyone who
was watching this
imagine if it was you and you know
remind yourself of the scenes that we've
seen of ukrainians fleeing for their
lives having to make treacherous
dangerous journeys
highly traumatized
and having to put their lives back
together while simply plonking someone
anywhere with any kind of roof over
their head
frankly is not good enough and does not
show compassion
and does not reflect the the importance
of always seeing the face behind the
case
yeah i think i think that sort of
lack of thought definitely comes through
with it i mean
the site itself i mean turning away from
just whether stafford is big enough to
support this and and and that kind of
local concern i mean seems quite
unsuitable to me i mean it's a former
student accommodation it'll be broken up
into little blocks where everyone's sort
of sharing about i think it's about five
people to a kitchen often sharing a
bathroom do you think that's kind of a
common thing going on at the moment and
and is that quite bad or what's your
view on that
well we work in a lot of hotels
supporting people who are in the asylum
system
and you know we've found that the
accommodation invariably is is pretty
basic
you know it's of a simple standard
and
we've seen situations where people have
kind of mobility issues and they're put
on higher floors with no lifts
we've seen situations where people have
underlying kidney problems and they're
not able to to
access to to basically have sufficient
drinking water
you know we've also seen situations
where people have particularly dietary
needs because of their health conditions
and they're not able to eat sufficient
foods so they suffer you know
significant weight loss
i mean this tells the story of people
being
put in accommodation which doesn't meet
their needs which causes them
significant suffering and human distress
and
really
we should be able to do better than that
we should be able to offer a basic
standard which
does demonstrate compassion which does
meet people's needs what's really
interesting and we've been looking into
this is that when one of the housing
providers like in in the case that
you've looked into serco
actually has to find accommodation
they have to do what is called a
compliance check
and that compliance check is pretty
basic it's about basic health and safety
say for example are there locks on the
door are there batteries
in the alarms and in the fire alarms and
so forth now that compliance check
i've been told by one of the housing
providers frankly doesn't look at any of
the needs assessments of the people that
are in this accommodation like those in
stafford and in hotels
and in their view isn't good enough
because
it's important to remember that people
are in this accommodation for months on
end and if you're there for months on
end crammed into hotel accommodation or
crammed into the accommodation that
you've been writing about
then a simple compliance check isn't
good enough you should be looking at
things like access
to services
to the local community to other support
that any individual will need because
you know imagine if if one had to be
in a cramped hotel room and we're also
talking about families here in hotels
rooms for months on in not just single
males
it would be enough to drive anyone to
to to more than distraction but to deep
despair
i think that definitely comes through i
mean i was looking a lot of sort of
circo submissions to the council and it
is obviously they're submitting it with
a very particular audience in mind there
but it's interesting how much of it is
concerned with basically really basic
things of just like oh will it increase
traffic in the area um you know will it
add strain to local services and you
start to think well
maybe that's a small factor but
obviously this used to be student
accommodation so that's not going to be
make a huge impact but is you're dealing
with a group of residents here many will
have pretty bad mental health issues
they'll be sort of fleeing war zones
they might have trauma there's also the
added complication they'll be coming
from nationalities all over the world
some of those won't get on even
internally you know there'll be
personality clashes or there'll be
clashes with people
inside your own country and it just does
seem at the moment like there's it's
kind of no force is put into that it's
all very much on the hoof i mean do you
get that impression as well
i do i mean i think as i say the home
office is in is in crisis mode it's been
in crisis mode for a long time
and actually the chief inspector of
borders uh was speaking in parliament
just yesterday and he and he said this
himself he said the home office is
having to deal with crisis after crisis
and therefore is unable to operate a
system which meets the needs of those
that are that are there and let's
remember you know men women and children
who as you say are highly traumatized
will be experiencing things like
post-traumatic stress disorder
flashbacks all kinds of anxieties
um and a left you know their their
mobile phones are taken off them when
they arrive so they have no means of
communicating with people initially they
arrive with sometimes just flip-flops
you know i've met
young adults who've arrived here with
simply flip-flops and a t-shirt and a
pair of trousers they don't have
anything they don't have toiletries
um
so you know we need to treat them with
dignity and human compassion and i don't
think because the system is in crisis
mode it is able to do that
and i'd be interested to hear your
viewer i mean it's been a bit of a
concern of this magazine and i mentioned
it a bit in my piece
um about this home office policy which
says that if you're claiming asylum you
can't work
and i think the idea from the home
office's point of view is that they
don't want sort of people coming over
and using it to like make a load of
money and then be kicked out and send it
home and that can sort of for the system
to be taken advantage of but i guess the
point we're making is that if you want
if people are here already and you want
them to sort of integrate a bit into the
local community and support themselves
it's and sort of keep them active and
busy as well offering work is is a good
thing for that i mean is that your view
as well or do you think because of the
relatively small time maybe smaller
times because we're looking at that
isn't that it's not such a huge thing
no it's absolutely my view that we
should be allowing people to work i mean
you know let's remember that the latest
home office data shows that three
quarters
of people are found to have a
well-founded fear of persecution and
therefore allowed to stay in the uk as
refugees and go on to settle in this
country as british citizens
so if that's the case why don't we allow
them to work from from the moment they
arrive
enable them to
earn their own money so the state so we
don't have to spend money on supporting
them allow them to be economically
independent because if they if if the
vast majority of three quarters are
going to be allowed to stay in the uk
anyway
then we should be supporting them to to
to be independent to allow them to work
and you know this happens in most other
countries
many countries allow people in the
asylum system to work sometimes at the
limit of three months or six months
until they can do so
but you know i've spoken to senior
conservative politicians who agree with
this you know they think it's absolutely
ludicrous that
the treasury is having to spend money
the home office having to spend large
amounts of money on people who could be
economically self-sufficient because
people who come here
are often incredibly hard-working
incredibly motivated they go on to run
businesses to contribute to the uk once
they're allowed to stay in the uk
and to be hard-working taxpayers that
play by the rules so
allowing people to work to me is an
obvious thing to do especially when
there's already skill shortages
and turning slightly so we've discussed
a lot about sort of the experience from
the refugees side
um
you know i mentioned this in the piece
that there's a lot quite a lot of local
backlash to the scheme in stafford
residents are pretty annoyed they're
kind of their concerns a lot about it i
think some of it is to do with control
as well because this is sort of just
announced unilaterally it sounds like
the council doesn't have much capacity
to to disprove it but then also there's
a lot of concern about strain on local
services
and safeguarding issues and so on i mean
do you think those those
concerns are fair and and do you think
sort of the home office and these sort
of companies don't manage the sort of
local communities well at the moment or
is there more they can do perhaps
there's definitely more that the home
office can do you know i understand why
local communities have these concerns
you know that you know
it makes sense suddenly something
is being landed on them there's been no
consultation no prior
preparation
and understandably they have lots of
questions and concerns the fundamental
problem here
is that the home office is not working
well with local councils you know we've
seen this consistently
in relation to all matters concerning
refugees so when there was the rapid
evacuation of people out of afghanistan
almost a year ago
the home office did no pre-planning with
local authorities with councils across
the country
they stood up hotels at last minute they
didn't even tell councils that they were
doing that and councils were finding out
after afghan families with large numbers
of children were being placed in in
inappropriate hotel accommodation often
you know we came across cases of hotels
by very busy main roads clear
safeguarding issues with the children
councils didn't know about it and this
creates a situation
where councils and the home office are
at loggerheads they're not working in
conjunction it's not collaboration
there's not proper planning
and you have this very adversarial
system which i don't think
creates a mechanism for local
communities to then
be in a position where they can
understand and make sense of what of
what happens
and i think we should mention because
i'm not sure we mentioned right at the
beginning actually but we talked about
the processing backlog there and
just in some respects it has been
increased by the uh by an increase in
channel crossings but it kind of goes
back much further than that and i think
since sort of 2018 is rocketed so it's
pre-covered it's pre and increasing
channel crossings and it does seem to be
the home office's fault for this i mean
i can't see any other sort of rational
explanation for it um
then
do you think so the the accommodation
policy at the moment is kind of based on
this sort of rough formula there should
be no more than one in 200 asylum
seekers in each local authority
the system seems to have been brought
about because
most migrants were originally claiming
in london or the south east and it
seemed unfair for them to all bunch
there so the idea is they're sort of
dispersed across the country
it has been a bit sort of slap showed in
a bit and it's clearly like areas which
are a bit cheaper that have taken the
the largest burden of this
um in my view it doesn't seem quite fit
for purpose and we probably need a bit
more of a think about which areas work
best i mean is that your view as well or
do you you know do you think it needs a
bit of a complete overhaul even it needs
look a total overhaul what what they've
done in ireland interestingly is they've
they've gone back to the drawing board
they've got housing associations to come
around the table to work with government
and to create a system of providing
accommodation
for people in the community we need to
allow people
to work so they can be economically
self-sufficient we need to ensure that
they have access to social housing
um like all groups that are in in need
and that have particular needs some
people will be able to work straight
away get a job and move into private
rental accommodation there's no reason
why they won't be able to do that they
might need a rental deposit scheme which
and we run one of those in london for
people who do get refugee status
but we need a a radical
radically different new approach here
because
tinkering with the system trying to
to resolve a crisis through further
crisis management
is not going to make the situation any
better it's simply going to make the
situation worse and there's a very
simple solution allowing people to work
bringing in housing associations social
landlords you know the outpouring of
support for people
including housing providers both private
providers and social providers vis-a-vis
ukrainians and afghans has been
remarkable so
you know i think there's a there's a
willingness and a desire here but
there's a political barrier the
government you know wants to create a
hostile environment
and
it will continue to do that it will
continue to create a system where there
has to be crisis management because it's
obsessed with ensuring that we do have a
hostile environment um brilliant ember
and i could talk about this all day but
i think that's all we've got time for so
thank you very much for coming on
are the swedes particularly inhospitable
the online world has been swirling with
horror stories about swedish hospitality
this week with our nordic neighbours
castigated as uniquely unfriendly in
europe the swedish journalist lisa
berwald has written a defense of sweden
for the spectator website this week she
joins me now
thank you for joining us on spectator tv
lisa now lisa's to start off swedish
hospitality has been given a bit of a
beating in recent weeks the swedes have
been accused of lots of things of
coldness aloofness the rest but before
we get a bit into the defense of that um
can you tell us a bit where this sort of
row or this idea has come from
yes
um so it started as just a basic use a
conversation on the reddit forum um
people were saying like what's the
weirdest thing you've experienced from
other countries that sort of thing
and someone was saying uh you know that
in sweden um you don't feed your kids
friends dinner you just let them sit in
the room
and everyone was like what that sounds
insane
and then this has exploded into um a
global debate with even you know you the
spectator uh new york times i saw i
think the cnn or msnbc was doing um
something on this story so it is
essentially pretty much a non-story from
a journalistic point of view
but now it is the story
so
so i'm you know i'm mildly concerned
with sweden's reputation but i'm also
amused so
so that's that's how it started but even
the premise of that is actually wrong um
because uh if you would have followed
that conversation but this story took on
a life of its own right um but the fact
is that uh even though some swedes don't
feed their friend the kids friends
it's actually more like the friends go
home and eat with their family
so the whole premise is wrong it's more
like we're not as social as spaniards or
italians
um that would just say anyone could come
in off the street it's this warm climate
this loose thing we're more reserved you
eat with your own family
and you'd rather wait and then you go
home at 5 30 when you're a kid to have
dinner with your own set of parents and
siblings
that's good i'm glad i'm just strict
but not
not weird yeah i'm sorry i'm glad
children are being fed in sweden um
another aspect of this is about
so
sort
of
it's like it's like um yeah it's like a
slight difference here in like refusing
to feed other children
and um our social kind of
circumstances and our social norms and
rules i mean so another aspect of this
is sort of guests come round and i think
sort of southern european countries are
much more likely to feed their guests or
give them food and that kind of thing
and sweden seems to be the sort of
opposite end of that is that kind of
fair as well
well
it's difficult to say i mean if a
neighbor would pop by
and
perhaps just wanting to borrow something
from a suite you would absolutely tend
to just land him or her that object and
a say like okay have a nice evening bye
um whereas if you go to turkey or greece
you're treated to like a five-course
meal and um you know we sweets are we
quite international people we we all
study abroad we live abroad we work
abroad
um
so we are kind of self-aware
of this lack of warmth
but yeah but i have to blame the weather
as well because you really do want a big
part of the year you just want to get
get in do your stuff and then get out
again whereas you don't want to hang
around
um so i think that has a lot to do with
it the literal warmth of the country as
well as the the social warmth right i
mean i mean god this has been studied in
in like academic studies for a year
hasn't it so this is all
um but yeah the funny thing about this
debate is it's no longer about like
meatballs or your childhood
it's about everything that's wrong with
swedish society and that's why the
hashtag swedengate was created right
i mean you mentioned there about warmth
i mean is it fair to say i mean is it
unfair to say probably that swedes are a
bit less warm as a people as well or do
you think that's that's too far or is
there some hidden hidden depths of
warmth that we've not realized
no no no we're just really cold like all
the way through
and i know this because my mother-in-law
is from singapore and you know just the
way you invite people the way you bond
over cooking
um we just we really don't have that do
you know the world values map anyone can
watching this can google it it's about
what kind of values you have is it
family is it religion what do you
prioritize in life
and you will find that sweden is
such an outlier i mean here's like the
rest of the world and you will find
sweden up there in that corner uh we are
super individualists yeah we don't care
about the church we're super secular uh
we don't really care about family or
these social things we only care about
self-development and career and
individual
success and prosperity if you look at
the world values map and this has
something to do with it as well it's
like
if you don't really care to get on with
um other families or neighbors why you
can invite them for food like so
spontaneously you can send them an
invite a few times a year to some formal
event instead that's very difficult i'm
only semi joking here yes we have
we have this proof of this in scientific
studies
so swedes seem very comfortable as they
are i mean what's their sort of reaction
been to this sort of worldwide
condemnation now then are they happy
about it or
kind of relaxed
well i mean there is an aspect that
isn't really i mean in all seriousness
it's not that much to joke about and it
is that we are in a pretty um
serious time period right now since we
have announced that we will be applying
for nato membership and we have been
informed by various security experts
here that this is a very uncertain
period there can be all manner of like
military threats disinformation threats
propaganda everything coming from russia
because they are obviously incredibly
vexed that um finland even shares a
border
with russia and we're just across the
baltic sea
and that we are now joining nato we have
been famously neutral
um although um
in real life we haven't been that
neutral we've been participating in nato
exercises for years and we weren't
really that neutral during the second
world war but officially we have been a
neutral country so obviously everyone's
been thinking
yeah it started off as a joke sweden
gate
but has there been any russian troll
factories involved in creating this
anti-sweden global phenomenon which the
debate is now
and uh
yeah the view here in stockholm is that
it's actually not unlikely
because what these straw factories and
online provocateurs do they take an
existing debate about something that's
negative for a country's reputation
which they obviously won't tarnish now
during the sensitive nato application
periods
and they just jump on it and they just
get their trolls to be like yes look
this is bad but also have you looked at
swedish healthcare and what about their
constitution so growing from
do we give our friends um coffee or tea
into what is wrong with swedish society
so you can absolutely um see that there
is a likelihood of
of outside influence on this whole
debate just
seeing how much it has grown it's not
really organic it's it's something that
it wouldn't be completely unlikely if
it has been added to the discussion you
know right well to try and put a bit
more of a positive spin on it i've heard
it sort of suggested
that one of the benefits of the nicer
side of say not feeding other people's
kids at your house is that it's more
about kind of respecting the boundaries
of other families and respecting the
privacy of the other families i mean do
you buy into that as well or do you
think that's that's pushing it
well i mean thinking back as a kid i
mean i love this habit
um i love that i didn't have to make
false conversation and sit there like
how was school
how is your family um it was like maybe
it was food you didn't like but you had
to eat it anyway you could just
stay and read comics in your friend's
room it was brilliant but you also have
to realize that it's i mean
swedes come from so many different
backgrounds social background cultural
background ethnic background i'm
obviously a very white person being born
and raised in stockholm which is pretty
a white capital city
in you know
and it's mainly middle class
so if you would ask someone who's black
and who grew up in a stockholm suburb
they would say they didn't have this
experience whatsoever that
in their multicultural part of swedish
society everyone came over and ate
everywhere and when and when i visited
friends who had like persian background
for example in the suburbs um there was
no way you were allowed to stay in the
room i mean you were literally dragged
to the table like what's wrong with you
eat you have to try 500 dishes
i would come home like shallow shock
notes like i was forced to socialize and
eat
strange objects
and my mom was like oh yeah but they're
not you know they're not swedish yet so
there's still hope that they could
become um cold and reserved like us in a
few generations
so to finish off then lisa as a sort of
final point i mean
is there anything the rest of the world
can learn from swedish hospitality
they've had a hard time are there any
positives that you think the rest of us
should sort of take away from that
no not at all it's it's all about us
swedes learning from other cultures it's
like it doesn't have to be uncomfortable
meeting new people i mean if you speak
to someone in sweden at a bus stop
they do think you are clinically insane
for just saying something like oh i
wonder when the bus buses coming they're
like why the hell are you chatting to me
you're a stranger um so other cultures
can teach us that it's it's not
dangerous to be a little bit more warm
open-minded um try new things and even
even share a meal with someone who's not
a blood relation to you
is sometimes fine
that's what we can learn
brilliant thank you very much lisa
and finally three people have already
died in the isle of man tt in this
year's racing sports journalist neil
clark as in this week's magazine that
despite the danger we should celebrate
the race for what it is to explain neil
joins me now
thank you for joining us on spectator tv
neil now in the magazine this week you
write about the isle of man tv rtt and
the sort of the danger and the glory of
it and it's been particularly prescient
this week which has seen multiple
fatalities over the week um
can you first of all before we get into
that tell us a bit about the race itself
um for viewers who aren't maybe that
familiar with it and what sort of the
attraction is there
well the isle of man tt
dates all the way back to 1907.
uh so you know it's 115 years old it's
held every year on the isle of man
uh apart downs uh hell every year since
then it's and the mounting course which
has been described as 38 miles of terror
probably the most
terrifying most frightening the most
difficult
road racing
motorcycling course in the world has
been used since 1911
and to give you some idea about how just
how dangerous it is since that time
before this year's tt there had been 151
fatalities of riders in the tt in the
alabama tt and on the mounting course as
a whole
uh 250. so we're talking about
where
uh it is i think it's only been two
years
uh after 1938
when we didn't have any fatalities
so it shows you that every year
unfortunately we do get at least one
fatality sometimes uh several and sadly
this year we have had already uh three
fatalities and uh also got one rider
critically injured in hospital and two
seriously injured
and what makes it so dangerous compared
to other motor races i mean is it the
course or is it is it the vehicles as
well that they're using are they
what's going on there
well the mounting course john 38 miles
of terror it's been called basically
your road racing on public roads
that have been there for all for a long
time uh you you backed by stone but most
of the time it's stone walls
you've got stone walls you've got trees
you've got lamp posts you've got
telegraph poles you've got houses so if
you come off for example at baligari
one of the most dangerous bends there
it's a fifth gear right-handed uh bend
riders going into it at incredible
speeds up you know sometimes they they
hit 200 miles an hour
you know if you get that wrong you're
going to end up you know against a wall
or a telegraph pole or some other
obstacle or tree and so uh you know it's
the nature of the course there's no
other road racing circuit like it in the
world and if you go on that course you
you you know it's it's a seal on
television is one thing to actually go
up
and see it yourself
you you you're you you know you
terrified yourself because you knew if
you were on that and you made just one
error then it could well be fatal so it
is the cause and of course and and it is
the speeds because
if you look at the history of the tt you
know when it first started uh to get 50
miles an hour goodness me that was a
major achievement uh then it went to uh
75 100
150 and now they're hitting 200 so the
machines have got i've got incredibly uh
so powerful nowadays the speeds they can
hit are really
quite incredible too and it's those
factors allied to the
uh the nature of the course means that
even though this year
the organizers have introduced a whole
raft of new safety measures
and we've still had unfortunately three
fatalities so it's it's the nature of
the beast really that it is it is it is
the ultimate test if you're a road racer
you have to do you have to do the isle
of man tt mounting course to sort of
prove yourself yeah i mean i was going
to ask that i'd say i mean if the risks
are so high why do you think drivers
still still want to take part in it
it's incredible i that i felt intensely
alive last week just being on the grid
before the start watching the bikers
getting ready to go off
uh hearing the engines revving up and
seeing them go around on their first lap
at 200 miles per hour i felt
intentionally alive and i was just a
spectator
what the guys who are actually riding
the feeling well it's off the scale uh
one driver said that it you know
it's a feeling that you hard to put into
words somebody said it was like flying
imagine going at 200 miles an hour on a
motorbike around that circuit uh uh it's
a buzz the excitement daley morgan
a tt veteran tragically killed only two
days ago age of 52 he was thinking of
retiring in 2019
then came the lockdowns the rest covered
restrictions etc he said he lost so much
from his life he felt so bored not being
able to to get on his motorbike and do
the tt he came back this year and he was
killed he took a big risk and
unfortunately didn't pay off for him but
the the philosophy of the riders is this
is that
they take the line that you know
eliakazam the famous film director said
you've got to risk your life every six
months to stay alive they risk their
life every time they go on that course
but for them it's worth it they
calculate that the risks they take are
worth it because the tremendous buzz the
acceleration that they get from riding
that course and that outweighs it it's
they make their own risk assessments
nobody's forcing them to do it
and they take the line that yes there is
a chance they might get killed but
against that
uh there's a chance they will complete
successfully and it's worth the risk
brilliant thank you neil for that
fascinating discussion thank you
that's it for this week once again why
not subscribe to the spectator magazine
and get 12 weeks of the magazine in
print and online for just 12 pounds also
give you a free 20 pound amazon gift
voucher go to spectator.com uk forward
slash tv offer to subscribe today
and don't forget to subscribe to the
spectator's youtube channel as well just
click the subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the bell icon so
you never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]